who the hell are you I am your destiny
episode 414 subject 9 now that Barry is
out of prison and after witnessing DeVoe
kill all the metahumans that he was
trying to free the last episode Barry
seen firsthand exactly how evil DeVoe is
and now he's taken upon himself to
really make sure that the remaining bus
metas are found and and saved why in the
name of God would anybody dangerous be
coming after me because you have powers
so they get a lead on the next bus Mehta
is he Bowen who is a rising country star
no no way
I hate country music I don't give a damn
what's your she also has the ability to
manipulate sound I guess now we know
what her power is what what yeah
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie the flash is back
let's break it down and there is a new
round of that flash ring giveaway - all
you have to do to enter it just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video you may have seen the really big
news while I was actually making this
video we got our first look is Zachary
Levi
Shazam costume so I'll address that a
little bit because it's a pretty
freaking big deal so expect them to drop
a bunch of official Shazam stuff really
really soon but as you can see from that
footage the flash producers confirmed
they're doing a version of the Fiddler's
from the comics now in the comics it's a
man it's Isaac Bowen he's an older
person either Senate British aristocrats
he's as gadget tree in his violin to
hypnotize people using those sound waves
so the way she's using it is a little
bit different like she's blowing stuff
up there might be some pyrotechnics
involved but I think part of the idea in
making her a country music star isn't
just making this something more
contemporary so like your hot version of
the Fiddler's is going to make elongated
man love country music I really think
I'm starting to like it now but like we
know we have this Jay Garrick episode
that's coming up I'll address some of
those pictures that they posted in this
- because the Fiddler's debuted in
all-flash quarterly which was the Jay
Garrick Golden Age era flash in December
of 1947 so just like a little while
after World War two and then he came
back again during the Silver Age during
the Barry Allen era and there was like a
Jay Garrick team-up where Fiddler's
teamed up with the thinker so obviously
it's a much different scenario on the
flash TV show the thinker is literally
just taking people's powers there
haven't really been that many metas that
have wanted to work with him like even
Kilgore who seemed pretty despicable and
probably would have worked with him
given the opportunity just ended up
dying after he sucked up all their
powers and then went into Becky's body
the interesting thing about Becky - the
actress that plays Dafoe's wife Marley's
actually said that she's not totally on
board with the plan so that's why they
used the tears like she definitely would
have bailed had to bow not roofied her
with those special tears that make
people love you
she also said some funny things about
what they've been doing with the
different bodies that the thinker has
been jumping into so I'll just let you
use your imagination but no everybody's
going crazy about the flash family
pictures that they dropped from episode
15 last night - so we got a
you of the Jay Garrick Jessie quick
episode there just them standing around
so killer frost is a big part of the
equation
it sounds like whatever happens with the
nuclear bomb that goes off that creates
the need for them to go into flash time
that happens after the episode picks up
so even though Jay Garrick isn't the
fastest he's been a speedster longer
than anyone else meaning he's learned
more skills than any of the other
Flash's so it sounds like one of those
episodes where he gives a mini tutorial
to Jesse quick and Barry like he does
that to Barry every once in a while when
he pops up in episodes like even though
we found out that Savitt R had been
traveling all over space time just
misleading people into thinking that he
was the original speedster Jay Garrick
was the one that gave that explainer to
Barry Lycos avatar is supposed to be the
first speedster now obviously he was fed
false information which is why he told
that to Barry but you just had to
imagine that there's a lot of tricks
that Jay Garrick has up his sleeve that
he hasn't revealed yet like he's been
the flash for 20-plus years so there's
probably a lot that he can do that we
won't have time to see till we get to
like season 5 speaking of which if you
didn't see it mark hamill did an
interview where he talked about his
trickster character and why we didn't
see in this season so during the
trickster family episode they just
reference in there like oh he took off
he doesn't care about this family and
they did jinks from the original series
he hasn't come looking for you he
doesn't care of course he does
but we'll mark hamill said is that the
producers asked him to come on he
accepted but because john wesley shipp
was busy doing a play when they were
gonna try and do their trickster episode
he just passed and said you know what
I'll wait till John Wesley Shipp can
guest star with me then we'll do an
episode together so the next time Mark
Hamill's trickster appears it will
probably be a Jay Garrick episode during
season 5 so a lot of times when they
don't use actors that you've been asking
about for a long time like how come we
don't do more Captain Cold it's mostly
just because the actors aren't available
they're off doing other TV shows or
something like that so no worries Mark
Hamill will always come back to the
flash regardless of what's going on with
Star Wars he did make a Star Wars joke
about being unemployed but again I think
that's just purposefully misleading
making a tongue-in-cheek joke like
obviously there's probably good
be some Luke Skywalker stuff happening
during episode 9 just not the way you
would traditionally expect it to happen
getting into the Shazam Captain Marvel
stuff I think what they're doing is
they're trying to do a version of The
Wiz comics the original Captain Marvel
Shazam costume so if you've been a fan
of the character for a long time
obviously you know he's the original
Captain Marvel but because of trademark
character issues lawyers arguing behind
the scenes Marvel's Captain Marvel will
be Captain Marvel Billy Batson will be
known as Shazam I'm hoping they make
some jokes about Fawcett comics Captain
Marvel stuff because it does sound like
they're pulling from a bunch of
different eras but just expect them to
drop an official reveal soon where we
get to see the front of the costume
we'll get a much better look at it
Superman anyone
[Music]
they're still in the middle of shooting
that movie right now obviously that's
how we got the look at Zachary Levi is
costume in no confirmation on Henry
Cavill involvement as Superman or gal
gadot as Wonder Woman but they've been
campaigning to get those stars in Henry
Cavill has been very open about his
desire to continue to be the Superman
character he has a very optimistic
outlook in stark contrast to Ben
Affleck's attitudes towards the future
of his Batman character Henry Cavill has
been more gung-ho about doing more
Superman inside the DC Universe but as
far as popping up in other people's
movies Shazam is just like the next best
place to put him Wonder Woman would have
to be some sort of tag at the beginning
of the end because that's gonna be
another period piece but I will do a DC
movie update when we get this Shazam
official preview from Warner Brothers
so that should come pretty soon but just
let me know in the comments just getting
this brief sort of teaser for the
costume what do you guys think of it so
far but what will happen is is I'm still
finishing my final space episode 1 video
obviously I'll post my flash episode
later tonight we're all announced that
giveaway winner but while you wait for
everything click here for that wally
west legends of tomorrow episode and
click here for brand new Deadpool and
learn about the Deadpool TV series thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight